[Musique]
j'ai des amis dans la chambre de mon
petit fils et lui le grenier jamais ça
me rend pas les choses plus difficiles
de son jeu est ma vie je me suis fait
envahir j'exigerai de récupérer ma
chambre où ce serait la guerre tu veux
pas qu'ils attaquent son grand-père
déclaration de guerre
tu as quelque chose qui m'appartient je
veux le récupérer mais le mois elles ont
effectué ration assurances ce genre
d'agression peut pas être ignorée sur le
grand père ne voit rien mais leur jeu
plus léché calmes
oh que ça sente pas de cette pièce c'est
vraiment la guerre passez une bonne
journée à l'école aux bisous aux
précédentes viennent montrer plus malin
que mon petit fils
on est en pleine lutte pour une chambre
j'ai bien eu je t'enlève prévenu
surveillance et surtout quelle belle
équipe vous fait les deux
je suis pas au courant pour l'un la
guerre de paris
c'est vraiment amusé pourquoi plus ces
monstres
bonjour à udine
[Musique]
un des enfants papier avec ses deux
filles le petit enfant
opi
au pire il les arrières petits enfants
on est vraiment désolé que tout refait
le chemin grâce au nul c'est ton grand
père qu'il faisait qu' on était une
famille la sidération passage où je
serai pas là j'en ai vient de m'appeler
days une blague c'est lui qui disait que
tout ce qui me séparait on était comme
une famille vous voulez un cercueil en
chêne léon cartuja non non c'est pas des
ménages ralentit
[Musique]
il
ça m'aurait fait plaisir que tu nous
appelles dans les joues à l'eau en neige
comme ça va tu as des petites phrases
comme ça des pertes
c'était quand même terme entendra pas
une émotion d'effectifs sont liés non je
t'assure se donnait vraiment envie de
mourir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma mère elle est 50% les gens viennent
donc moi
quand ces 25 je voudrais même de l'été
ce livre pour un test adn complet à
je trouve que c'est normal que l'âge que
j'ai toujours peur de toi et je m'en
veux d'avoir un esprit opposé
[Musique]
je veux par du trez-hir
pact et peur sert à tricher
[Musique]
à mon sens riffs tu peux être fier de
moi même
c'est ton sang qui coule dans les veines
je fais partie en année
[Musique]
fifa 12
la salle de type man who dat du groupe
union amis comme ça se fait pas
welcome to the resistance
ouais
du plateau textuel d'un cross non
carbone en france
[Musique]
mais tout coeur le rallye
tous viennent jouer sur la forme
[Musique]
l'unique but
pcb calais
[Musique]
le mauriennais mot chaque morceau
ça fait trois ans que je dise 1 300 ans
que je m'ennuie j'en ai marre d'être
toujours quoi si son papa dirigeants moi
je m'en fiche je quitte cette prison
le contre est fermé aux enfants à
l'école pour rencontrer des amis de mon
âge bienveillant de l'élève michel du
fonds qui est qu un vampire et je veux
être ton ami
bayon la petite oie tutoie pas de raison
d'avoir peur
faut pas que tes parents apprennent que
j'existe cm d'euros par an j'ai perdu
mes parents
bon tu vises amis ou des rigolos perdu
mes parents c'est une expression ça veut
dire qu'ils sont moi maman
les normands ils bougent plus jamais non
ils ne bougent plus chez nous c'est pas
pareil
il existe des êtres sur cette planète
qui peuvent nous faire mourir vraiment
le djibouti en colère
nous sauvera soit
je jure d'être un super contente au
petit vampire et de jamais dire tu ce
plan qui s'y met quand même des filles
si tu sors piscine admis tuerie serait
ta peau et l'autre moussaillons on va
l'autre dans la chimie tout son mari
chabot michel jarry
mais ne laissez pas partir entre codex à
cette façon de lui n'arrivera pas à
l'abordage
offer coup sauvés petit vampire et
éviter un châtiment est normal qu est-ce
qu aux morts aujourd'hui
veux que vous fermez les yeux et pensez
à un souvenir qui vous rend heureux
et penser à un souvenir que vous
associer à votre jeunesse
maintenant penser au souvenir le plus
douloureux de votre fille à présent
ouvrez les yeux ce dispositif
extrait le véritable souvenir du cerveau
et nous leur transmet
la machine est incroyable la vérité non
filtrée et pure
c'est une perte terrible mais je voulais
juste vous dire à quel point je suis
désolé comment avez vous connu gordon il
m'a sauvé la vie
on l'a retrouvé mort dans son bureau
avec des impacts de balles dans les murs
des impacts blessures par balles il
travaillait avec beaucoup de personnes
perturbées il doit découvrir ce qui vous
est arrivé gobain c'est le moins que je
puisse faire
on peut-être que je peux pas voir vous
souvenir et je peux voir les souvenirs
de ceux qu'ils étaient près de vous qui
êtes vous je travaille pour sa veuve
je sais que vous avez vues sur la
cheminée mais je peux vous aider
oui allison allison est morte
vous pensez qu'il cache la vérité il y a
des gens qui vous cherche si l'automne
homme a été assassiné
vous avez des choses plus importantes à
gérer
il ne faut pas qu'on sache que la
machine a disparu qu'est-ce que vous le
voulez je voulais vous poser quelques
questions sur gordon de sortie d'ici
notre esprit oubli des choses pour une
raison il y a des défauts à corriger
hallucinations perte de notion du temps
est ce que vous savez qui est cet homme
et l'automne a menti
parce que je pense savoir qui a tué leur
donne je serais très déçu si je
découvrais que vous manqué
à quelque chose que vous aimeriez
pouvoir oublier qui êtes-vous bcsa bcsa
aidez moi nenê je n'essaie prochaine
son nez
malaga comme ça
boudina
et cac mid100
écoutez je vais aussi coupé lemonade et
c'est plus qu'un manager de madonna di
luca
[Musique]
c'est cousu pour le numéro 8 mai
oh
née semaine le cas jean marc coma m'a
dit si tu étais qui s'y ajoutent rouge
moi je cours en l'espace de quarante
pays doivent ramasser doit doit se
trouver guerre terroriste et nos âmes
combien coûte au caucase du sud face au
mas
[Musique]
m
oui c'est magnifique
non même
m
où
je
[Applaudissements]
qu'y faire
[Musique]
m
consciente et baigorri
en gironde n'était pas peu dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
visiblement
[Musique]
tant que des soins
on connaît tous le toit
le bas s'évase mois